and we're going to establish what we're
going to need to label these two guys
which is our old familiar friend the
quadratic formula now before we get to
the quadratic formula okay what skill do
we have that allows us to get to the
quadratic formula how do we get that yep
completing this way very good so let's
consider just a neon quadratic we'll
stop thinking about this for a little
bit and let's think about this okay now
I picked a quadratic this is always the
quadratic I pick because everyone can
meet immediately see because we've been
dealing with these for long enough
everyone can see them roots of this
quadratic right and therefore by
implication the factors if you can't
remember what the difference between
those are we'll get to it in a second
right so really quickly how would you
expected that directly what would you
write down that's what I meant to say
okay so well done you succeeded okay
that's right the morning we're looking
for pair of numbers add to this multiply
to that and that's your prepare right
okay so that's one technique and that's
fine that's because these numbers are
needs how would we complete the square
if the numbers were not neat what the
same I want to use the same coordinate
because we know what the answers are yep
okay let's give this a go so x squared
plus 5x equals negative six
okay so what this number here this is
big yeah that's our second coefficient
their coefficient of x so I'm going to
have it square it let me say it again
Harvick square harvick script that's all
you have to do that's all there is to
the quadratic formula okay I'm gonna
have it which gives me two and a half
and when you square two and a half what
do you get you get six in a corner right
[ __ ] outta there I'd better add it here
so far so good yeah now the reason why I
did this why did I have and square what
was the point of harming and swearing
hmm
this guy over here is a perfect square
there needs to write this putt damage
just to remember right if you have
something like this what should I treat
I'll choose then I want to I want to let
on I'll put it to say okay if it's a
perfect square if it's a perfect square
then when you expand you're going to get
to see X plus C squared okay so I've got
I've got this piece here this is the
piece that I have right so to go from
this to this
you've Harbert that gives you C and then
you square it and that gives you C
square so I've heard it and it's where
that so now that's the perfect square
and I think climb back up here to
something or swear what's the something
it's there yeah it's the hard part right
it's just the C okay sir
what I've got over here it's just a
quick okay so this is good this is
better right I've made some progress I
have something factorized but what do I
do now okay I'm going to take the square
root of both sides because you just want
X right so I take it over here which
means on this side good because it's
it's squared not I don't have we have x
equals the square root or something
which is just one value right so I
actually have these so far so good
so now I'm gonna bring this guy over he
yep
so now I have minus 5 over 2 minus 1/2
that'll give me my left one that's minus
6 over 2 which is negative 3 or cause it
can't be both of these things at the
same time minus 5 over 2 plus 1/2 which
is minus 4 over 2 which is negative or
two okay so what have I done of those
two things mmm these guys here see these
guys X plus 3 and X plus 2 these are my
factors these are my factors just like
when you say 21 is 3 times 7
this is this times this right so this is
a product and these are the factors
these are not factors right because this
is not minus 3 times minus 2 right these
are not factors in fact they are you can
think of them a couple in 4 ways you can
call them roots because what they would
correspond to is where they collide at
these two points alternatively a bit
more of a technical way to say it is
they are zeros which is a bit confusing
when you say to someone oh yeah my 0 is
2 it's like another my 0 is 0 um what
that means is if you put either of these
in two here you get 0 it's what makes
the function 0 in other words if there's
solutions for this because that's what I
want equal to see ok sir that was
completing the square we didn't need you
because it was simple but now
yeah let's take a rather more difficult
version okay now I'm going to see if you
remember this I'll give you a minute
talking about it we walk through how to
complete the square in a simple
numerical example this is not a simple
non-numerical it's a bit complicated its
algebraic give it a shot and see if we
can get what you need to at the end